sir Anthony you play a character who's  pious and you project immense piety but  you told us that you are not even a  believer  I haven't say that agnostic you say yeah  well what is an agnostic is if it's  something you may have doubts I have  sometimes doubts and sometimes they  don't have those I don't have any doubts  anymore well yeah of course you have  doubts that's being human yeah I don't  know I don't know anything that's not  the greatest spiritual ethic of alter no  nothing but do you think he had doubts  of course is there any intelligent human  being will have doubts in doubt lives  piety in doubt lives humility if you  have certainty you're dead certainty  destroys people Hitler destroyed 40  million people because he was certain  Stalin destroyed millions of his own  people certainty because he knew no one  knows and the greatest way to live is to  have be living constantly in doubt  [Music]